To understand really what's going on with faults, errors, and
failures let's look at an example. Things always start with
a fault. And our fault example is a programming mistake.
And let's say that programming mistake is an add function that
we wrote for our program. It works just fine in
all cases, except when we give it to add five
and three in which case it returns seven instead of
eight. This type of fault we also call a latent error.
It's not really an error until we do something
like this, but this type of a fault we
call latent error because it's only a matter of
time when it's going to be activated. So when we
actually execute 5 plus 3 and get 7 in
some register, we now have an error. If the
error is a result of some sort of a
latent error like this, basically a programming error, we say
that the fault has been activated or that we
now have an effective error as opposed to a latent
one. In our case we get the effective error
once we call the add function with 5 and 3
and get 7 instead of 8, and then we
put that value in some variable. We get the failure
when the system deviates from specified behavior. For example,
in this case it might be that the time we
were computing is the time to schedule a meeting
for, and now we schedule a meeting for seven,
instead of eight, as expected. And this is basically
the failure of the system because it didn't effectively schedule
the meeting for when it was supposed to. It
is important to note here that you need a fault
of some sort in order to get an error,
but not every fault becomes an error. For the fault
of this type, for example, to become an error, it needs to be activated. We
need to actually use the function in a way that makes it produce incorrect
results, even though it always had a fault. It always was faulty in this
way. Similarly, we can have an error and never get a failure.
For example here, if this value seven was never used, and programs
often do this, then we have an error, a
variable has the wrong value, but we don't get
a failure as a result. Another example here would
be something like, if we check for example whether this
function returns something larger than zero, then when it
returns seven instead of eight and we store that in
a register, compare it to zero, see that it's
still larger than zero, now we got an effective error,
because a register held the wrong value, but the
only thing we did with this value still caused
the program to function normally. So in this case,
we have an error, but we don't have a failure.